ochse kamel oder elefant während
tausenden von jahren hat das pferd serie
ausgestochen
als reformmotor schlachtross und
statussymbol wurde es zum politischen
tiere und wichtigsten gefährten des
menschen erst die technische revolution
besiegelte den bruch des kennt audition
pakt zwischen pferd und homo sapiens
ulrich raulff direktor des deutschen
literaturarchivs marbach hat den exodus
des perthes aus unserer welt
nachgezeichnet heraus 2013 haben sie von
deutschen bundespräsidenten gauck das
verdienstkreuz erster klasse erhalten
und zwar mit der begründung dass sie
sich in die kulturellen in den
kulturellen diskurs als wichtige stimme
in deutschland einbauen
nun haben sie ein pferde buch
geschrieben warum weil ich fand das dass
es sehr erstaunlich war dass wir das
pferd soweit vergessen haben
dabei ist es unser wichtigster partner
gewesen durch 6000 jahre geschichte
hindurch und dieser dieser pakt zwischen
menschen und pferden ich bin so weit
gegangen dass als kentaur ischen hakt zu
beschreiben hat sich innerhalb sehr
kurzer zeit aufgelöst
das ist das eine was mich erstaunt und
das andere dass dieses dieser auflösung
fast vergessen ist jetzt in eine
auflösung sagten sie ein ist es ein eine
trennungsgeschichte als auch ein ein
sentimentales ein emotionales buch ja
natürlich also es ist auch ein bisschen
ein emotionales buch ich glaube also
über pferde pferde sind er hat ja nicht
von sich aus nicht unbedingt emotionale
tiere aber von uns aus natürlich alles
sehr sehr mit sehr viele emotionen
umgebene tiere und und gesehene erlebte
tiere
ich glaube über pferde kann man keinen
kein buch kalt schreiben also wie man es
jetzt über die geschichte wird vorsicht
ist des automobils vielleicht könnte
schon das ist auch viele emotionen
hängen aber eben auch das biografisch
natürlich kommt die frage ich werde sie
nicht stellen ob sie selber entfernt
besitzen aber sie wird man dieses buch
ihrer mutter und sagen dass ihre mutter
eine eine sehr enge beziehung zu fällen
gehabt hat sie hatten vermutlich eine
enge beziehung zu ihrer mutter hätte
ihre mutter dieses buch gelesen
ich hoffe dass es ihr gefallen hätte ich
kann sich leider nicht mal fragen
sie war ein echtes pferde mädchen und
ist das eigentlich zeitlebens geblieben
also meine mutter wusste war es ein
gutes pferd ist und sie wusste auch wie
man wie man an ein gutes pferd kommt
aber das sagen sie waren kein pferde
junge ich war nicht in dem sinne ein
fertig war der sohn eines pferde mädchen
sagen wir so und auch eines eines
pferdebegeisterten vaters ich bin mit
verein groß geworden für oder oder
richtiger gesagt unter fährten groß
geworden denn ich lag mir ja drunter ist
dass ich drauf saß aber ich bin dann
generationen typisch irgendwie so um die
puppe täter um den pferden untreu
geworden und zu den autos motorräder und
über übergelaufen sehen sie doch eine
alternative für die emotionen jetzt ihre
dieser abschied zwischen pferd und oder
zwischen ross und reiter ist ja eine
große geschichte auch des krieges darauf
kommen sicher noch detailliert zu
sprechen
aber diese dieser dieser abschied das
heißt es ist ein martialischer
geschichte und ist das pferd mit seinem
weggang aus unserer realen lebenswelt
auch aus unseren köpfen raus sein dass
gerade gar nicht
ich würde fast sagen im gegenteil also
im selben maß wie wir uns das beginnt ja
früh im neunzehnten jahrhundert also
dass man vom abschied vom pferd zu reden
beginnt
das beginnt also mit diesen mit diesen
geschichten nachdem tambora ausbruch
also mit der verbesserung der welt und
den missernten soweit das ist ja keine
ist eine diese kleine eiszeit in den in
denen 1816 als 17 oder 18 jahren
da beginnt man zum ersten mal davon zu
reden dass man irgendwann ohne
pferdewirt leben müssen und auf ihr
leben können da erfindet der freiherr
von drais das laufrad und so also da ist
so der gedanke von technisch mobilität
zum ersten mal im breiteren schichten da
und dann dann setzt sich das fort ganz
19 jahrhundert vollzogen wird es
eigentlich im relativ kurzen zeitraum um
die jahrhundertwende im lauf von
ungefähr 20 jahren aber dieser dieser
prozess selber ist schon ein sehr
dramatischer wenn man sich das genau
ansieht und das hat mich sehr
beschäftigt
also das heißt es ist zwar vollzogen
historisch schon lange es ist spuk das
pferd da werden wir auch darauf zu
sprechen kommen immer noch in unseren
köpfen und in unseren herzen aber wenn
sie jetzt diese geschichte des abschieds
geschrieben haben geht es auch darum dem
pferd gerechtigkeit widerfahren zu
lassen
ja also da steckt man historiker herz
eben auch also ich habe eben auch ein
begriff von historischer gerechtigkeit
und dazu gehört dass die pferde die
unsere wichtigsten partner überhaupt
also in der in der auch in der in der
menschheitsgeschichte gewesen sind und
unsere wichtigen partner beim machen von
dem was man geschichte nennt also diesem
gigantischen entwicklungsprozess in dem
wir uns sehr sehr stark verändert haben
und die pferde mit uns das ist ein
wechselseitiger prozess gewesen dass der
dass der eine partner so vergessen ist
heute und die die leistung der beitrag
der große beitrag gefährte zur
geschichte so gut für vergessen ist und
das wollte ich wieder gutmachen
das kann man das so als historical also
wie man das mit anderen in anderen
bereichen beschreibt auch dem pferd zu
ordnen dass du sagt dass das pferd jetzt
teil unserer geschichte wird also seine
eigenen geschichte ja das ist glaube ich
mittlerweile im gang es gibt also eine
ganze reihe von von jungen historiker
und historikerinnen kultur
wissenschaftlerinnen die über animal
history oder schreiben oder oder eine
monster dies betreiben also in
historischer perspektive
das finde ich also ganz toll dass das
tatsächlich jetzt also sich unter unter
jüngeren historikern ausbreitet
zuschauen wie haben tatsächlich menschen
und tiere miteinander gelebt miteinander
agiert wie haben sie sich gegenseitig
geformt im lauf der geschichte
wie ist es eigentlich sie sind ja ach
wie war sie hatten sich intensiv mit api
wahlprogramms einander gesetzt und wie
ist es eigentlich mit der quellenlage
die quellenlage ist überwältigend es
erschlagen
ich arbeite sehr gerne im archiv also
nicht nur weil ich jetzt sein
ich leite sondern ich habe auch mein
leben lang gern im archiv gearbeitet
aber mit diesem punkt bin ich kann nicht
bis ins archiv gekommen weil davor also
eine riesige ein anwalt von von büchern
liegt also es ist über das pferd seit
dem 16 jahrhundert ist über das pferd
geschrieben worden wie über keinen
anderen gegenständen dieser oder kein
anderes wesen in dieser welt außer über
die menschen und es sind es hunde oder
also wenn man nicht nein überhaupt nicht
vergleichbar hatten die die runde sind
auch sehr wichtig gewesen immer für die
menschen und ihnen sehr nahe sie gerade
sehr wichtige emotionale gefährten und
sicherheitstechnisch auch nicht zu
unterschätzen
katzen sind erst in jüngster zeit also
so kometen gleich aufgestiegen also das
ist das ist er
eine geschichte des internet ich dachte
eher an bord ist ja also natürlich hat
die katze ihr bescheidenes auskommen in
der literatur gehabt also neben den
mäusen denken sie an kafkas von denen
sie sich genähert hat aber das pferd ist
eine ganz andere geschichte das pferd
hat bibliotheken entstehen sehen und
auch diese bibliotheken sind
verschwunden
in antiquariaten bei sammlern und so
weiter findet sich das alles noch aber
es ist vollkommen aus unserem geistigen
horizont verschwunden
aber will man ist dann sozusagen
archäologisch ausgräbt diese bibliothek
ist mann erschlagen also davon von der
fülle von von büchern die über pferde
geschrieben worden sind
das war auch ein bisschen mein eindruck
natürlich beim nächsten zu spüren es war
unglaublich wie sie wie sie eigentlich
überall wo sie hinschauen wo es in
welches buch zu nehmen können sie ihre
geschichte weiter ziehen und man kann
quasi seine eigene pferde geschichte
noch noch mit integrieren was natürlich
nicht sehr interessiert hat ist an
diesem abschied an dieser an diesem
langen trennungsprozess natürlich die
die technologie und die
industrialisierung im 19 jahrhundert und
wir haben aktuell feiern wir mit dem
gotthard basis tunnel in der schweiz
quasi dritte etappe der abschied ist
lang längst vollzogen und man spürt dass
man vor 136 jahren als das erste
gotthard-tunnel durchbrochen wurde gab
es noch diesen war bildhaften kampf
zwischen der fernseh stärke entfernt und
und der heißen waren heute beim bau des
tunnels sieht man nichts mehr und man
sieht zwei einen eingang und einen
ausgang und eine bundeskanzlerin und
drei präsidenten die in einem vierer
abteil zusammen wasser trinken aber es
gibt keine erotischen bilder mehr dieser
dieser neuen prozesse und wir haben aber
etwas vorbereitet ein spielfilm
ausschnitt aber bevor wir uns den
anschauen möchten wir zuerst über die
gotthard post kurz reden sie kennen
dieses ganz berühmte schweizer
bild darf es das wirklich ins ins
kollektive bewusstsein eingegangen nicht
was sagt es ihnen
naja es sagt eben diese diesen
zusammenstoß der verschiedenen zeiten
den man da sieht also das sind ja das
bild hat seine dramatik und seine
dynamik also aus der derzeit differenzen
im choral differenz zwischen diesen
diesen unglaublich dynamisch
heranstürmenden pferden und diesem etwas
hilflos verängstigt davon trabenden kalb
also man wünscht es nicht aber man man
ahnt es könnte es könnte zum unfall
kommen und dadurch vermittelt das ganze
also vermittelt nicht nur dynamik
sondern also auch eine eine latente
dramatik das bild und die dramatik ist
natürlich eine metaphorische dahinter
steht eben der abschied also von der
alten welt die die die langsame welt der
der der gotthard überquerung also mit
mit animalischer kraft
jetzt ist bricht ein anderes zeitalter
an
das ist also die metapher also der der
alten nicht langsamen aber doch ganz
ganz anders funktionierenden und das war
ja auch ein gutes beispiel
quasi über die kraft der fährt er
metaphorisch dass es uns heute noch
anspricht dieses bild das war schon
überholt war zur zeit als es gemalt
wurde
für alfred escher als als geschenk für
dieses gotthard-tunnel projekte
eisenbahn und unser grosser schweizer
germanist peter von matt hat ja ein
ganzes buch betitelt mit dem charakter
gotthard post und zieht natürlich auch
in diesem kampf seine eine seiner ersten
fragen als intellektueller mensch der
sich jeglicher wird dieses kalb
davonkommen
und natürlich wissen wir alle es wird
tote geben bei jedem dieser kulturellen
oder industriellen prozesse und wir sind
ja auch in einer solchen situation wurde
nicht wissen
kriegen wir die kutsche oder oder sind
sie das kalb oder gehören wir einfach zu
den klotzen
führen die diese geschwindigkeit nicht
einmal begreifen und nachvollziehen
können ja insofern ist das eine der
großen ikonen also der technischen
modernisierung die da im hintergrund
spürbar ist im hintergrund lauert so wie
zum beispiel auch tanas berühmtes bild
von diesem eisenbahnzug der darauf durch
das bild gefahren kommt rains team an
speed was man nicht sieht ist das vor
der eisenbahn vor der eisenbahn ein hase
läuft und der ist einer ähnlichen
situation will das kalb und jeder fragt
sich also wie wird das ausgehen also
dieses dieses rennende der ungleichen
partner
sie geben mir dass gutes stichwort für
unseren ersten film ein spieler es gibt
einen spielfilm gotthard da heute abend
um 20 05 auf sf1 läuft und hier sehen
wir dieses wettrennen noch quasi in
einer parallelität aber man sieht dann
wieder zug vorbei zieht das schauen wir
uns ganz schnell an
[Musik]
dass das was sie sagt und das rennen ist
es aber verloren aber die sympathie
liegt er bei ja weil sie sagen ist nicht
einfach zu sagen oder wenn man
lokomotive ist oder nein weil wir diese
lokomotiven diesen zug natürlich jetzt
auch schon wieder ein genaues
nostalgisch als dampfross uns uns
anschauen aber die frage der
geschwindigkeit ist eine eine eine frage
unserer gegenwart
die frage der mobilität ist eine frage
der gegenwart und das heißt also dass
dieser diese trennungsgeschichte wir
wieder lesen können mit davor sich auch
noch einmal die sie beschreiben mit dem
pferd aber gibt es ganz biografisch also
dann zu sagen sie waren kein zweiter
junger er unternehmensumfeld gefallen
und nicht wieder live gehört wie wir
haben sie dynamiken oder mobilität in
ihrer eigenen biografie erfahren als als
shift oder wechseln
also ich nehme mir daneben sie haben
gesagt der führerschein war dann das
thema ja natürlich obwohl der
führerschein scheint auch immer schon
sozusagen transkribiert war
überschritten war weil ich jahre vorher
bin ich schon auto gefahren dann alles
trecker gefahren also was mir in die
finger fiel also damit fuhr ich also
lange bevor der führerschein überhaupt
als möglichkeit in sicht kam deshalb
fühle ich dann auch prompt durch die
durch die prüfung weil ich also gewöhnt
weil ja ich fuhr nach meinen eigenen
regeln gut und später habe ich natürlich
dynamiken unterschiedlichster art kennen
gelernt das ist nicht alles nur sagen
wir mal klassische transport mobilität
also natürlich lernt man alle
verkehrssystem im laufes des lebens
kennen und und fühlt sich mal als
gewinner einmal als als opfer dieser
dieser mobilität aber man erlebt sie
natürlich auch auf lebenspraktisch
beruflich durch viele umzüge oder so ich
bin zeit war es also wie ein normaler
durch die welt gezogen
insofern ist mobilität vielleicht dass
das größte und am stärksten prägende
thema so unseres lebens und also wie
sehen sie das jetzt in der nächsten
generation das ja auch interessant das
spüre ich dass die jungen menschen
dienst jetzt nicht mehr für autos zum
beispiel führerschein verliere was sie
so ist es mein sohn ist 25 und hat noch
keinen führerschein
weil es ihn auch gar nicht in der weise
interessiert also so panisch
interessiert wie es mich tat also dass
auch das reisen erlebt und die mobilität
erlebt eine eine virtualisierung also
und findet offenbar jetzt also stärker
medial vermittelt in den in den köpfen
oder in virtuellen räumen schnell dann
diese diese virtuellen räume oder die
die denkräume also wenn man jetzt sich
den wilden westen noch einmal vorstellt
und und dann wild west roman liest und
man kann man überhaupt also in unserer
wahrnehmung von raum und zeit in unserer
realen welt und uns schaffen
überhaupt diese art von raum lähmung
durch das pferd den planwagen überhaupt
noch vergegenwärtigen
naja durch durch jahrhunderte und
jahrtausende weg hat sich eben mobilität
immer mit dem mit dem pferd verbunden
das pferd ist sozusagen die ikone ist
der inbegriff von von bewegungsenergie
und insofern ist natürlich auch raum
nahm die eroberung von von räumen und so
weiter ist mit mit pferden verbunden
gewesen
es gab auch ein paar andere tiere die
man dafür benutzen konnte kamele und so
weiter ochsen sie haben das ja zu beginn
gesagt aber das schnellste und und
dynamischen und damit auch effektivste
tier ist das pferd gewesen
oswald spengler hat das unnachahmlich
zum ausdruck gebracht hat gesagt durch
die pferde kommt
das tempo in die geschichte und damit
wird überhaupt eigentlich erst der der
raum der geschichte aufgemacht weil
jetzt beginnt oder ist die möglichkeit
für große politik da das ist ein
bisschen niekisch mit nietzsche
gesprochen große politik aber das heißt
einfach weit ausgreifende große räume
erobernde besetzende und und sichernde
potenz ist durch das pferd da also sind
wir auch es gibt immer auf den krieg so
immer man die geschichte sich sich
anschaut zwischen mensch und pferd also
wenn der krieg wenn wir das ein bisschen
jetzt nachzuarbeiten versuchen der krieg
die mutter aller dinge ist ist dann das
pferd dann motors aller dinge gewesen
ja das kann man schon sagen also wir
haben ja bis vor 120 150 jahren je
nachdem also welche welche motoren man
schaut
dampfmaschinen haben wir ja nun schon
etwas länger haben wir ja keinen anderen
lieferanten kinetischer energie gehabt
als das pferd den ochsen und so weiter
aber die waren alle viel langsamer also
wenn es schnell gehen musste und im
krieg muss es natürlich schnell gehen
jetzt um schnelle bewegungen vor allen
dingen im modernen krieg sowie napoleon
ihn in die welt gebracht hat geht es
eben um einen sehr schnellen um einen
überraschungs krieg im grunde genommen
das die gesamte blitzkrieg strategie ist
ja schon ein napoleonisches ist nicht
eine sache des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
und das geht eben nur mit pferden also
insofern ist das pferd natürlich steht
das pferd auch lange zeit im zentrum des
des modernen schnellen krieges und wie
muss man sich das vorstellen ein fertig
sein pferd vor 6000 jahren wie sie das
gesagt haben ist das begleitet uns aber
der fortschritt eines pferdes sich sehr
beschränkt es kann ja nicht plötzlich
doppelt so stark sein oder treiben also
schnell also wie muss man denn die sich
diesen fortschritt vorstellen ist das
strategisch oder ist das
und wieso sind die ich weiß nicht
die hunde fährt und haben das gewesen
als napoleon werden
die sind auch schon sehr sehr schnell
gewesen oder sie haben die gleiche
geschwindigkeit gehabt aber die
bewaffnung ist noch eine andere
und natürlich der der stil der
kriegführung also die franzosen haben
sozusagen diesen schnell und krieg noch
mal neu erfunden und napoleon der hier
eigentlich at leer ist gewesen ist
übrigens ist die artillerie dann
natürlich die zweite entscheidende waffe
das des modernen krieges napoleon hat
diesen schnellen krieg noch mal neu
erfunden und da war für sagen wir mal
ein halbes jahrhundert war die
kavallerie die schlacht entscheidende
waffe schlechthin also die die sozusagen
die branche brach und dann kam die
infanterie hinterher
also da war da wurde das tempo also
selbst als waffe eingesetzt also das
tempo bleibt konstant also deswegen auch
diese einheit der pferdestärke wie es
uns uns bis heute begleitet also ist ist
wie sie fertig werke quasi die
universelle energie einheit per se ja
natürlich also wir haben uns nicht dran
dazu bekehren lassen also in kw zu
rechnen wir rechnen immer noch in
pferdestärken weil das so anschaulich
ist für uns eben dass das kann man sich
ohne weiteres vorstellen was das heißt
wenn wenn eine maschine so stark ist wie
50 pferde oder können sie uns erklären
was sind eigentlich fertig stärken
naja das ist ein maß das man also zuerst
in england gefunden hat und und dann
ungefähr gleichzeitig in frankreich und
da hat man festgelegt also wie viel
kilogramm in kurzer zeit seit einer
sekunde wie viele meter weit
transportiert werden können und warum
braucht es diese definition
naja dann hat man ein standardmaß dann
kann man sagen also eine eine maschine
oder eine eine kombinierte einheit aus
menschen
tieren ist so und so stark da kann man
kann man rechnen also was man damit
bewirken kann jetzt einfach das sind die
technische energieeinheit aber das pferd
und das beschreiben sie ja auch ist auch
eine art geldmaschine auf der rennbahn
also das spielerische das spekulative
element des perthes spielt auch eine
eine wichtige rolle
ja das ist wieder etwas was die was die
engländer erfunden haben eher die haben
das nicht dass pferderennen schlechthin
erfunden also rennen mit pferden hat man
vorher schon gemacht aber das waren eher
spontan organisierte geschichten die
engländer systematisieren dass die legen
die großen renn plätze an die züchten
pferde bei denen es alles nur noch auf
schnelligkeit ankommt also selbst
schönheit droht auf den zweiten platz zu
rutschen
alle anderen eigenschaften sind sowieso
und wichtig entscheidend ist die
qualität eines fährt ist bemisst sich
nach geschwindigkeit und dann
kombinieren sie das ganze noch mit einem
wettsystem das also dann sich sehr
schnell ausbreite popularisiert und auch
die die niederen schichten einsteigen
lässt also in dieses dieses system also
die könige stiften preise reiten selbst
ran mit
aber auch die die arbeiterklasse kann
betten
also ist interessantes integratives und
wenn man so will also fast
demokratisches modell was die engländer
da entwickelt haben sportmodell und das
war 18 bis 19
das ist 18 jahren hat im wesentlichen
also das beginnt im siebzehnten und das
setzt sich im 19
weiter fort und wird dann also geht wie
eine epidemie über den ganzen
europäischen kontinent alle nationen die
irgendwie auf sich halten legen sich ein
plätze zu das ist also
das ist sozusagen das das große ding
also für nicht nur für den europäischen
adels sondern auch für das für das
großbürgertum das bürgertum und so
weiter so das sind das sind stätten an
denen gesellschaftlich also sehr sehr
viel gespielt wird und sehr sehr viele
entschieden wird
deshalb spielen auch so viele der großen
romane des 19 jahrhunderts auf dem einen
platz oder haben entscheidende szenen
auf dem rennplatz deshalb werden rennen
auch so viel gemalt aber auch kickt
moment also oder also sozusagen
wetteinsatz man gewinnt oder man
verliert
na ja also es ist ein schicksals
maschinen haben sie so werden diese
schicksals sind wir wieder nochmals beim
krieg oder also dieses schicksals
maschine und dass das potenzial zur
identifikation geht ja so weit dass sie
das diesen kennt arischen packt nennen
also diese verschmelzung wird was zu
einem dritten wesen mit mit einem pferd
das heißt das pferd auch mit ihrem
leiter verschmelzen und dass dieser
katholische packt wenn der reiter stirbt
wenn der reiter wegfällt eine eigene
ganz starke ikonografische kraft hat und
sie beschreiben dass ein trauerzug von
kennedy aber wir haben einen kleinen
trauerzug in der schweiz auch mit erlebt
wo vielleicht auch das zum letzten mal
in der geschichte so spürbar war dass
das noch authentisch wirkt beim tod des
general die songs der die schweizer
armee befehligt hat während des zweiten
weltkriegs 1960 in lausanne und die
wochenschau also darüber berichtet
so zieht der tote durch die schweigende
ergriffene menge
[Musik]
den militärischen befehlshaber gibt die
landesregierung das letzte geleit den
bundesräten folgen die alt bundesräte
die mit general guisan schwere
verantwortung getragen haben
ein ergreifender augenblick die 400
feldzeichen grüßen den general zum
letzten mal dieselben fahnen und
standarten von denen die am ende des
aktiven dienstes in so bewegender weise
abschied genommen hat und wie in alten
tagen folgt das pferd dem sage seines
toten herrn wie in alten tagen und
trotzdem in der zeit ja das ist aber
auch natürlich ein extrem starkes
zeichen hörte dass begegnet einem jahr
also wirklich hier ein stück wie eine
alte nadel aus der vorzeit die die
plötzlichen die gegenwart ragt also das
ist spätestens in dem augenblick
durchläuft an ihren schauer wenn man das
sieht und das ist bei den amerikanischen
präsidenten die amerikaner steigern
das noch die die intensität und dramatik
dieses bildes dadurch dass sie die
reitstiefel verkehrt in die steigbügel
die leeren stiefel verkehrt rum in die
stadt über stellen die bedeutung
dafür gibt es mehrere es gibt
historische erklärung das wird auf die
römer zurückgeführt es wird auf barocke
trauerzeremonie ahl zurückgeführt ich
glaube es ist einfach so ein ungeheuer
starkes bild dafür dass der der
kommandeur nicht mehr da ist dass die
szene verlassen hat und manche sagen das
ist so ein bild dafür dass er sich ein
letztes mal umwendet recht denn fährt
und auf die auf die zurückgebliebene
jetzt verwaiste truppe zurück schaut
aber das sind alles so merkwürdige
konstruktion
eigentlich geht es nur um diese die
qualität dieses bildes dies einfach
fabelhaft durch nichts zu übertreffen
das ist dass man das spürt das ist nicht
mehr gibt danach also ein bisschen
flapsig mit
mit der analogie gesagt wenn jetzt heute
ein tunnel eröffnet werden dann dann ist
nichts mehr zu sehen dass man dann
zurückgreift und dass man immer bei
diesem abschied vom pferd wenn er dann
wirklich ernst wird und wenn er sich
nicht so langsam und in phasen verzieht
dass es dann zu großen emotionen auch
kommt und zu großen ängsten und zu zu
verunsicherungen ist in der schweizer
geschichte noch einmal wichtig und auch
mit dem militär verbunden als die
kavallerie abgeschafft wurde
und ich glaube die schweiz war das
letzte land dann anfangs der 70er jahre
die wirklich sich verabschiedet hat von
der kavallerie es gab petitionen dagegen
eine halbe million unterschriften dass
man das nicht machen darf was vermutlich
völlig irrational weil das war die rolle
eines festes in einem modernen krieg
auch hier haben wir einen kleinen
ausschnitt als tag schafft von damals wo
diese emotionalität gezeigt und spürbar
wird zum letzten mal zum letzten mal
stehen ross und reiter vor ihrem
kommandanten zum letzten mal grüßt der
kommandant die standarten seines
regimentes
[Musik]
zum letzten mal hat sich ein
schweizerisches drittes kavallerie
regiment feldmark mäßig besonders mehr
als 30.000 zuschauer haben sich im hass
von der schweizerischen kavallerie
verabschiedet
[Musik]
zum letzten mal zum letzten mal
immer wieder holt das drückt natürlich
die ganze dramatik aus und die
ergriffenheit der beteiligten und dann
natürlich also kein zufall dass der dass
der vorneweg reitende der der führer der
anführer auf einem weißen pferd sitzen
das ist sozusagen das alter
apokalyptische zeichen die herrschaft
mussten immer als als nachfolger christi
auf dem weißen pferd sitzen und das hat
natürlich unser unser bild von
herrschaft geprägt über jahrhunderte
hinweg konnte man sich also die die
macht die internierte macht nicht anders
vorstellen als man auf fährt also dass
das unsere heutigen machthaber irgendwie
aus verdunkelten acht zylindern
gekrabbelt kommen
das ist eine ganz rezente geschichte und
natürlich also wäre es ein bis zu den
job von zeit zu zeit ja sicher aber ich
meine frau merkel offen fährt ist er
eine schwierige vor china elisabeth
kriminalist ja nun gott sie ist nun
wirklich ein fairer mädchen gewesen und
zeitlebens geblieben das heißt ja sie
liebt hunde pferde und männer und zwar
in der reihenfolge fährte mädchen also
wir haben jetzt die männer gehabt
die männer die geschichte machen das
pferd das mit dem mann zusammen
geschichte macht und man spürt dass das
offensichtlich immer auch hätten
nationale geschichten sind es ist das
pferd repräsentiert die nation hier in
der schweiz
aber für mich ist speziell weil ist die
schweiz nicht unbedingt ein ein
pferdeland wie man es von den polen oder
von anderen nach unter den engländern
und den franzosen gehen kann
also ist es dann ein universelles ob sie
die cia für nationale identität
ja das ist das lässt sich
nationalisieren und das habe neben
vielen nationen im laufe der geschichte
der europäischen geschichte namentlich
haben das getan haben das pferd zu ihrem
eigenen leben tier gemacht
weil es natürlich auch jetzt wieder ganz
am anfang also durch seine dynamik durch
seinen ausdruck also von von von kraft
von schnelligkeit verbunden mit
schönheit und so sich natürlich viel
besser dafür eignet eine nation in all
dem was sie begehrenswert was sie stark
was sie stolz macht zu repräsentieren
hast meinetwegen jetzt ein an eine kuh
einen hohen 1 1 ein schwein ein schwan
nur der löwe kann mit dem pferd kommt ja
aber der löwe ist das erstaunliche ist
das pferd ist ja gleichzeitig nutzt hier
es ist ein nutzt hier und es ist die die
diese wunderbare politische ikone auf
dem die löwen als nutztier da ist nichts
so richtig anzufangen
diese verbindung noch einmal also gar
nicht sagt er man kann es
nationalisieren und jetzt wäre ein um
das pferd genommen oder es verschwindet
und dann gibt es ja auch logistische
fragen bei unsererseits gibt es dieses
nationalgestüt das immer dieses rolle
war zwischen landwirtschaft und militär
und zucht und und
und politik und politik und also man
merkt jetzt wie die kavallerie zieht aus
und ich habe auch in der vorbereitung
zur fernsehbeiträge gesehen aus den
siebziger jahren dann wo man zieht ihr
die mädchen in dieses nationalgestüt
einziehen also dass im sub texas wird
nicht gesagt aber man spürt die haben
dann so alte militär jacken und mäntel
an die noch neigen wohl umgingen und
benutzen dann plötzlich diese kutschen
und diese pferde und es gibt so eine
plötzlich ein neues leben wie
durchmarsch nicht mehr die männer reiten
soll die mädchen plötzlich um und zieht
sich sogar uniformteile an sehen aus wie
die hippies mit lang haben also die
demontieren etwas aber es gibt eine neue
geschichte und deswegen wirklich gern
ein bisschen über die frauen mädchen
insbesondere und und das pferd spricht
na ja aber das ist das ist schon
interessant also das was vorher war es
interessant weil tatsächlich also über
dass das pferd man natürlich auch
nochmal mit mit seiner nation verbunden
sein kann denn jeder der an ein pferd
besitzt und ein pferd reiten ein
verpflegt und so weiter kann sich ja in
die auch in die kavallerie hinein
imaginieren kann sich also in die indy
es teil der nation fühlen so gut jetzt
ist dieses kapitel abgeschlossen jetzt
kommen die pferde mädchen das ist noch
mal ein ganz interessantes kapitel der
feminisierung oder wenn man so will der
der wirken easy rung also der der der
pferdewelt das ist ein ganz junges
kapitel in der pferde geschichte das
eigentlich erst mit der zweiten hälfte
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts beginnt
also da wo so die große heroische pferde
epoche zu ende geht also in der schweiz
mit der kavallerie gibt es noch etwas
länger ich dachte immer dass sein so in
den 50er jahren
die russen haben ich dachte mir die
russen sein drittliga wir aufgehört
haben
das ist 55 aber ich hatte nicht an die
schweiz gedacht das geht uns auf zu die
schweiz ist von einem bezaubernden
konservativismus jedenfalls in dem
bereich gewesen
und hat nun aber eben auch die die
kavallerie kampflos an die mädchen
übergeben und die wenn sie heute mit
alten pferde männern reden also züchtern
und und reitern und ehemaligen café
touristen dann sagen die selber die
jungen frauen die mädchen halten die
pferde am leben wir hätten nur noch halb
so viele pferde wenn ich die die die
frauen sie im besitz genommen hätten
oder sich hätten in besitz nehmen lassen
von den pferden
denn das ist ja eine gegenseitige
verfügungs relation also dann werden
jetzt es gibt einen anderen kennt
arischen pakt zwischen männern und fährt
und frauen für mich der kentaro ja schon
eigentlich dieses männlich animalische
triebwesen ist dass sich frauen cloud
und und und also aller böcklin ja die
welt galoppiert oder dann vielleicht
manchmal in die dorfschmiede geht
trotzdem es ist ein ein viriler sexual
sondern ein ganz schlimmer burschen also
natürlich auch zu prügeleien und so
jederzeit bereit gut und dessen zeit ist
vorbei und nun haben die amazonen
übernommen bis in die amazon ischen
zeitalter aber daten wir natürlich
wieder eine referenz tief in die in die
vorgeschichte fast hinein ab denn diese
amazonen eigentlich aber natürlich kann
es die soja es gibt auch viele trat uhr
darüber also die beschreibt das ist also
diesen diesen anderen verschiedenen
packt also zwischen zwischen frauen- und
werden auch immer gegeben hat und
zwischen zwischen reitenden kriegerinnen
also das hat es in allen kulturen und
zwischen den kulturen immer mal wieder
gegeben es ist nur nie hat sich nie
durchsetzen können also gegenüber dem
dem kämpferischen dem die männlichen
pakt bis heute aber jetzt hat sich das
das blatt der geschichte gewendet aber
eben die frauen würden keinen kennt
arischen pakt eingehen sondern sind
amazonen oder ist es das gleiche gibt es
weibliche konnten
es kommt darauf an was man mit kind
trauern meint also wenn man mit
kentauren also diese diese rauflustigen
burschen dann ist das natürlich also was
ganz anderes
das ist heute anders geändert bei den
amazonen das sind reiten will kriegerin
also am dach ist ist die bekannteste
amazone in der europäischen geschichte
gewesen und dann hat es noch noch ein
paar andere gegeben also bis zu queen
elizabeth nein das ist heute das ist
auch sicher ein ganz anderer packt der
beruht auf auf anderen voraussetzungen
denn die pferde mädchen verbinden sich
mit den pferden nicht um krieg zu führen
oder noch nicht mal am umlagen zu gehen
also auf höchster zu jagen oder so
irgendwie solche solche heldenhaften
geschichten oder so das interessiert ja
gar nicht die machen die suchen ja was
ganz anderes
also ich habe eine tochter die weiter 8
ist und schwer vom pferd gefallen ist
jetzt ist alles wieder gut aber mich
interessieren sich genau diese frage was
um gottes weg interessiert was sagt ihre
tochter dazu ja dass sie das nicht also
es ist lustig also sie erklärt sie mir
nicht es ist ein geheimnis
ich vermute gewisse dinge aber das
möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen ich meine
aber er diese art von dass es keine
jungs gibt ist wichtig glaube ich und
dass sie obwohl sie vom rost gefallen
ist irgendwie eine art von nähe oder
vertrauen in dieses tier hat ja also ich
habe auch mal die erfahrung gemacht dass
ein pferde mädchen direkt gefragt also
was da eigentlich dahinter steckt genau
diesen begriff geraucht hatten gesagt
hat vertrauen und ich glaube das ist
wirklich eine ganz wichtige geschichte
also dass man dass man so viel
selbstvertrauen zunächst mal wickelt
dass man diesen diesem
sehr viel größeren und und potenziell
gefährlichen tier vertrauen schenken
darf und dass man dass man mit diesem
mit diesem ganz anders gearteten
lebewesen eine freundschaft schließen
und die jungs welt ist weit draußen auch
die eltern welt ist weit weg na ja genau
daher haben sie gesagt mit dem geheimnis
die lehrer die schule
das alles ist weg es ist es geht
wirklich um eine eine verbindung
zwischen einem sehr großen der starken
potenziell gefährlichen tier das aber
auch ein sehr schönes und wohlriechend
das hier ist unglaublich schönen augen
und diesen diesen jungen mädchen die da
auch dinge erproben können auch in sich
selbst auch zum beispiel aggressive
härtere geschichten für die es sonst
keinen raum gibt in der normalen welt
es ist interessant also wenn man sagt
also der mann oder krieger der iss einen
gruß in die schlacht führt das stück das
rost das eigentlich ein fluchttier ist
wird selbst zu einem schreckens element
in der masse drin auch und etwas aus mir
was ich mir noch nie überlegt habe und
bei der lektüre so aufgefallen ist dass
offensichtlich immer auch in
kriegerischen kontext ist einen großen
ein großes potenzial an mitleid gab mit
dem pferd im kriegerischen kommt dass
man mehr mitleid mit dem zerschossenen
vierte quartal von gehabt hat als mit
dem mit den männern und die da 2000 und
hunderttausenden in den schützengräben
liegen nach dem ersten weltkrieg
also das heißt auch der mann hat ein
emotionales verhältnis das ein
sentimentales verhältnis zum pferd und
heute im liebe durch die ponys mädchens
zum zum pferd dass das pferd eine
therapie und und
zivilisationskrankheiten heilendes
fetisch tier geworden ist
ja also ich glaube das wird das pferd
wird sicher noch eine große rolle
spielen in unserer zivilisation nicht
nur als als sport und freizeit begleiter
sondern
vielleicht eben auch in dieser weise ist
als therapie als therapeut und
vielleicht auch als lehrer also doch wir
können immer noch viel vom fernen lernen
denn so wie jedes junge fährt also die
die ganze geschichte also der der
gewöhnung an den menschen der
unterdrückung seiner fluchtreflexe das
ausschalten seiner seiner seiner
natürlichen panik sobald sich ein mensch
auf seinen rücken setzt so wie jedes
junge fährt dieses ganze pensum noch mal
lernen muss was also die die pferde über
jahrtausende gelernt haben
so muss ja auch jeder mensch im grunde
genommen noch mal diesen ganzen
zivilisations prozess wie norbert elias
gesagt hat durchlaufen
jede generation muster wieder durch und
dabei also gerade bei dem erlernen und
all dessen was wir meinen wenn wir von
menschlichen eigenschaften also
verständnis
ganz anders gearteter wesen einschulung
dieses sich hineinversetzen können in
andere dass dafür gibt es keinen
besseren lehrer als das pferd jetzt
etwas was einen dann schon sehr erstaunt
ist dass wir vergessen
in diesem kontext tun sie das nicht aber
es gibt feste metzgereien und es gibt es
gibt eine tradition oder vertex zu essen
und sie ich habe zweimal versucht einmal
ohne es zu wissen und einmal wissentlich
und also weil ich ich wollte wissen wie
es wie es wie es ist wie es schmeckt und
auch wie ich reagiere
also ob ich eventuell was weiß ich das
nicht kann aber ich konnte es nun gut
jetzt weiß ich wie es wie es ist und
muss es nicht weiter betreiben
ja wir können dass ich meine ich mich
markets und ist das kälbchen vor der
gotthard post verschwunden aber ich mag
auch kälbchen furchtbar gern ich mag sie
gern
als gericht zubereitet aber ich mag sie
immer auch gern als als als lebende
wesen auf der wiese und ich finde es
außerordentlich grausam also wenn ich
einem lebenden kälbchen gegner oder im
revier vorzustellen dass ich dass ich es
auch wenige stunden später vielleicht
essen könnte aber so sind wir also wenn
wir nicht nicht vegetarier oder veganer
weiß dass es gewisse tabus gibt dass ich
mein hund habe ich jetzt zum beispiel
noch nie gegessen da auch loewe jaja
fährt ist ein angrenzenden also für
viele kulturen ist es ist tabu das pferd
zu essen und für viele ist es ein
leckerbissen
und es ist es ist eine sehr sehr
komplizierte geschichte ich bin da in
meinem buch kann nicht darauf
eingegangen weil sie viel zu kompliziert
ist weil sich das in den kulturen auch
noch mal wieder ändert also auch mit den
mit den religionen verbunden sich sehr
stark ändern kann also für das
christentum ist das pferd er ist ein
lange zeit absolut tabu und später ist
es das nicht mehr
also wie kommt das und so weiter also
wieso machen einige völker den den den
anfang die franzosen zum beispiel auch
erst im 18 jahrhundert und deshalb
verweigern sich andere nationen also dem
komplett wirklich gerne wenn die
amerikaner hat zum beispiel also
amerikanische pferde werden alle nicht
in amerika verzehrt sondern werden also
wenn sie geschlachtet werden nach europa
verkauft diesen zivilisatorischen
verbessert das gleicht das lässt mich
nicht los also zu sagen wir müssen alle
nochmals durch diese ganze 6000 jährige
geschichte dann bist du mir vielleicht
zum schluss unseres gespräch wirklich
mal an dem beginn nochmals gehen sagt
wie sind sie überhaupt zusammen gekommen
diese beiden tiere
naja das ist eines der großen
kulturgeschichtlichen rätsel oder anders
ein rätsel das ist vielleicht
übertrieben aber es ist ein
das ist ein interessantes problem für
jeden historiker weil wir haben es beim
pferd ja mit ein fluchttier zu tun also
pferde wildpferde
haben den natürlichen reflex die
begegnung mit den menschen zu vermeiden
für die ist der mensch sehr realistisch
gedacht vom pferd ein potenzieller
gefährdet außerdem geht man besser aus
dem weg und wenn die pferde sich nun
irgendwie an die nähe von menschen
gewöhnt haben oder gar von menschen
eingefangen worden sind dann ist es
trotzdem also für die pferde immer noch
eine eine katastrophale erfahrung wenn
das pferd wenn der mensch auf die idee
kommt sich auf seinen rücken setzen zu
wollen
was ist das heißt es ist reziprok also
das pferd muss auch nochmals durch die
ganze geschichte durch jeder vollen und
geräten werden ja jedes junge fohlen
reitet man nicht zu aber ein solides
jedes junge fährt also im alter von drei
oder vier jahren muss durch diese
katastrophe hindurchgehen auf die es
nicht anders als panisch reagieren kann
weil es seien seien natürliche anlage
seien es ein ganzer instinkt apparat
sagt ihm das ist höchste gefahr
es ist wie wenn ein löwe mich von den
anspringt genau so ist das wenn sich ein
mensch auf mich auf meinen rücken setzt
das ist fährt er reagiert also sofort
mit mit panik mit flucht und es muss
ganz vorsichtig aus seinem instinkt
programm gelöst werden und dieses
programm muss neu zusammen gesetzt
werden damit es lernt den reiter als
sein sein freund und und auch als sein
sein sein lenker zu akzeptieren und
darin nicht endlich gefahr zu sehen
das muss jedes pferd jeder generation
wieder neu lernen und durch diesen
diesen sozusagen diesen hypo
zivilisations prozess gehen und wir
müssen halt durch unseren antrag
zivilisations prozess gehen als wir
müssen menschen werden
durch das für und und dabei hilft uns
das wird aber das heißt wenn das pferd
also eigentlich ist es eine eine
medaille aus also das heißt wir tun dem
pferd gewalt dann seit 6000 jahren seit
wir auf die idee gekommen sind uns zu
potenzieren und das ist ein alter packt
den sie nennen den dokumentarischen
praktisch einseitig also wir schließen
mit dem vater fährt wird von
generationen zu generationen wieder
traumatisiert und muss domestiziert
werden
wieso hat man in all diesen 6000 jahren
nicht fertig gezüchtet die diese
instinkte nicht mehr haben
das geht glaube ich nicht sie können das
vielleicht ein bisschen dämpfen aber sie
können das nicht nicht grundsätzlich um
prohlis nicht nein das wollen sie auch
das wollen wir auch gar nicht man würde
ihnen die wildheit austreiben
das kann man durch durch kastrationen ja
so teilweise aber wenn sie sagen ich
muss sagen dass sie mir wo findet keine
stadt unsere ganze medaillons mit der
welt unserer unser ganzes verhältnisse
mit der welt ist eine medaille aus unser
verhältnis zu bäumen unsere verhältnis
zu auch zu technischen objekten lauter
medaillon cen
also wir sind eine zumutung für alle
eigentlich ja und für alle alle objekte
die uns umgeben alle wesen die uns
umgeben nur zwischen zwischen menschen
meinen wir dass zeitweise aufheben zu
können und und zu allianzen kommen zu
können zur verbindungen die keine
medaillen sind also keine falschen oder
verfehlten allianzen sind wir zum
beispiel begreift sich so und und also
wir müssen uns nicht darüber unterhalten
wie für medaillons da ständig passiert
nichts versteht langsam den begriff des
lehrers also das pferd als als lehrer
dass wenn ich durch diesen ja im besten
sinne neben schon auch eine art von
therapeutischen prozess mit dem reiten
mit dem pferd im umgang mit dem pferd
geht dass sich an dieser brutalen grund
disposition die ich mitbringe
auch etwas wie respekt
eben um vertrauen sogar demut lernen
kann gegenüber diesen überlegenen
fluchttier ja so ist es also und das ist
das ist ein pensum das ihnen vielleicht
kein kein anderes wesen die menschen
eingeschlossen also in der weise so
perfekt erteilen kann wie eben gerade
das pferd das wissen nicht zuletzt alte
kavalleristen also wie wir sie gesehen
haben die wissen dass man das das beste
was wir ihnen geben können dass geben
sie ihnen nur das geben sie ihnen
freiwillig das geben sie ihnen aus
freundschaft das geben sie ihnen aus
liebe nicht auf kommando
das heißt der krieger der mit mit
waffengewalt in den krieg zieht hat ein
tier das er mit und mit kleinsten gesten
[Musik]
kontrolliert also ist eine sehr
ambivalente situation ja ja wir sehen
immer nur dass es dieses martialische
wild also das große boom boom aber dass
die entscheidende verbindung ganz anders
hergestellt wird so wie sie sagen also
über über winzige im grunde genommen
winzige stromstöße über die verbindung
zweier zwei animalischer durchblutet
aqaba wurde eine vitale kybernetik das
sehen wir nicht
das ist das entscheidende die instinkte
des pferdes dass wir die in ihrer in
ihrer fragilität brauchen um einen an
unseren eigenen instinkten im positiven
sinn zu arbeiten oder und und bessere
menschen zu werden braucht das pferd
ja und wir können auch noch vieles
lernen in zukunft jetzt also mal ganz
theologisch gesprochen wir können noch
sehr vieles lernen über das
zusammenwirken von von verschiedensten
wesen
was also nicht über über ratio über
sprache
über unsere üblichen zeichensysteme
läuft sondern also direkt im grunde
genommen also in einer in einer ganz
direkten weise also körperliche
mitteilung ist ja da oder acht mit einer
ambivalenz umzugehen weil es letztlich
wie sie sagen es ist eine form von
missbrauch was mir mit dem pferd machen
aber es gibt eine chance irgendwie das
zu überwinden
ja in einer fusion oder in diesen kennt
arischen packt ja es gibt die chance der
freundschaft ja jetzt sind wir fast am
schluss etwas was mir gefallen hat
dieses porno zu kaiser will mit dem
zweiten das berühmte dass er sagt ja ich
halte das das auto für eine momentane
modeerscheinung was bleiben wird ist das
pferd da lacht man darüber und dann
liest man hier buchen da denkt man
vielleicht war das ein visionär
also kommt das pferd zurück in unsere
städte in unserem verkehr in unsere ja
also ich träume davon irgendwie die die
bürgermeister die alle mit dem feinstaub
problem mit der feinstaubbelastung zu
kämpfen haben zu beraten und zu sagen es
doch ganz einfach stellt um auf
fußgänger fahrräder und reiter stellt um
wieder zurück re konversion wird aufs
pferd das wäre die lösung und ich meine
wir reden natürlich also auch schon
davon dass das in zukunft die autos
entweder selbst fahren sollen oder
verschwinden werden zum großen teil
wieder zivilisation verschwinden werden
wo sie kommen seit 150 jahren vielleicht
unterwegs sind also deshalb eises härter
hat als 6000 jahre gedauert jetzt die so
150 oder vielleicht 200 jahre auto
dagegen was ist da schon das halten sie
durchaus für realistisch dass wir
dereinst wieder die ängste haben wir uns
vorfahren im 19 4 19 jahrhundert gesagt
wir werden in kubikmetern von pferdemist
die unsere städte überwuchern ersticken
denn ist nicht mehr der feinstaub
sondern der pferdeäpfel wieder unsere
große angst in den ställen das kann sein
aber die auf die angst würde ich gerne
mal ankommen lassen
wunderbar vielen herzlichen dank für das
gespräch
danke ingo schneider die sternstunde
kümmert sich weiter um enge beziehungen
nächste woche haben wir den großen
französischen philosophen allein bei
youtube gast der brillante provokateur
plädiert für die kraft der liebe und
hier geht es gleich weiter mit den
wolken sammler ein porträt über den
künstler oder mann
[Musik]